[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition de présidentielle 360 voici les
titres la sécurité des candidats en
question après l'arrestation de deux
hommes suspectés de préparer un attentat
à 5 jours du premier tour les photos des
suspects avaient été distribuées au
service d'ordre d'Emmanuel Macron et de
Marine Le Pen et franç Fillon informé
des menaces le détail dans un instant
suite de notre série consacré à la
campagne présidentielle vue du terrain
nos équipe ont suivi la candidate
frontiste la semaine dernière en
haut-vienne et le leader d'en marche
lors de son meeting à Paris Bercy hier
reportage et décryptage à suivre jamais
un scrutin n'a été aussi serré
l'incertitude reste totale et l'issue du
vote devrait se jouer dans un mouchoir
de poche les indécis sont nombreux et la
volatilité de l'électorat rend difficile
tout prononstique dans ce ce contexte
quel crédit accorder au sondage on en
parlera avec mes invités et je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir à cette
émission sur Twitter hashtag
présidentielle
360 la menace terroriste fait donc
irruption dans la campagne deux hommes
ont été interpellés aujourd'hui à
Marseille soupçonnés de préparer un
attentat imminent la sécurité des
candidats a immédiatement été renforcée
à 5 jours du premier tour Stéphane
amalian des armes à feu et du matériel
explosif ont été retrouvé à leur
domicile dans le 3e arrondissement de
Marseille
des habitants du quartier ont assisté à
l'arrestation de l'un des suspects de
policiers je crois qu'ils sont pris des
distances ils ont sorti le revolver en
cas danger pour les leurs collègues et
après ils ont ils ont mis
le ilst mis le cagoule le Monot et après
il l'ont embarqué les deux hommes
étaient connus des services de
renseignement mais n'avaient été
incarcéré que pour des infraction de
droits commun leur arrestation fait
suite à une enquête du 12 avril pour
association de malfaiteurs terroristes
criminel les deux hommes radicalisés nés
respectivement en
1987 et
1993 de nationalité française avait
l'intention de commettre à très court
terme c'est-à-dire dans les tous
prochains jours un attentat sur le sol
français à quelques jours maintenant
d'une échéance électorale majeure pour
notre pays je veux rappeler que tout est
mis en œuvre pour assurer la sécurité de
ce rendez-vous majeur pour not notre
démocratie et pour notre République
certains candidats auraient été ciblés
par ces deux hommes la semaine dernière
les équipes des candidats ont été
avertis du risque avéré d'attentat
certains avaient même reçu les photos
des deux suspects Mathias fkel a annoncé
le renforcement de la sécurité pour le
premier tour de la présidentielle avec
50000 policiers et gendarmes assistés
par les militaires de l'opération
sentinelle pour surveiller les quelques
67000 bureaux de vote dernière ligne
droite pour les candidats avant le verd
dicte des urnes dimanche pour Emmanuel
Macron dont la campagne s'essouffle le
meeting de Bercy hier à Paris s'estmé en
démonstration de force il a réuni
environ 20000 personnes beaucoup de
marcheurs comme ils se définissent
Sandra serkira et Cecile Sisou sont
allés à la rencontre de ses soutiens
dont beaucoup vous allez le voir sont
des
néomilitants la salle de Bercy est
pleine à craquer pour beaucoup c'est
leur premier grand meeting maxime a
toujours regardé la politique de loin
sans jamais se retrouver dans aucun
parti il a adhéré au mouvement
d'Emmanuel Macron à sa création il y a
un an sans trop savoir dans quoi il
s'aventurait au départ on était pas
nombreux mais c'était je sais pas sil a
il a incarné une un esprit de jeunesse
de renouveau que beaucoup de personnes
attendaient jeune ou moins jeune environ
70 % des marcheurs vivent leur premier
engagement politique au côté d'Emmanuel
Macron comme Cécile qui a toujours voté
à gauche mais sans jamais m milité
depuis des mois elle participe au comité
local de clamar dans les hautes scènes
et a même déposé sa candidature pour
devenir député en marche et j'en viens à
discuter à faire du du porte à porte
avec des gens qui votaient Fillon vous
voyez avant vous voyez c'est c'est quand
même incroyable c'est quand même un très
bel espoir surtout à notre époque où on
voit tous ces climages qui apparaissent
tous ces tension de voir qu'on peut
travailler ensemble et que c'est
possible et dans dans la en plus dans la
bonne humeur dans la bienveillance déçu
par François Fillon et les affaires ce
militant a le cœur à droite mais il va
voter Macron un peu par défaut c'est le
seul qui soit à la fois pour moi
crédible et honnête il faut des
candidats un peu jeunes et tourner la
page quoi Nestor lui n'a jamais voté il
a fait la grande marche motivé par un
mouvement qui selon lui est le seul à
impliquer la base on était
absolument issu de la société civile on
est all les frapper dans les quartiers
pour dire pour pour poser des questions
essayer de recueillir la vie des gens
toutes les idées qu'on a recueilli sur
le terrain on les a retrouvé ça c'est ça
qui était fabuleux on les a retrouvé
dans le diagnostic qui a été ensuite
rendu public à l'automne 2016 et ensuite
dans le programme d'Emmanuel Macron
nous fébril l'équipe de campagne a bien
conscience que rien n'est joué et que le
premier tour de la présidentielle a
valeur de test malgré son statut de
favori Emmanuel Macron sait qu'il a
l'électorat le plus volatile et qu'il
doit vaincre jusqu'au bout les indécis
dans cette dernière semaine de campagne
il va pour cela privilégier les
déplacements plutôt que les réunions
publiques et dans ce scrutin il dit les
prétendants à l'Élysée agitent
régulièrement le spectre du vote utile
l'lecteurs se m alors en stratège mais
que ce soit à droite ou à gauche
l'interprétation n'est pas forcément la
même alors voter utile c'est voter pour
qui finalement élément de réponse avec
Flor
sauvage par conviction ou par stratégie
à 5 jours du premier tour de l'élection
présidenti
la question du vote utile taraude les
électeurs indécis un/4 des électeurs
envisagent de voter selon cette logique
du vote utile c'est exactement la même
proportion qu'en 2012 sauf Queen 2012
comme on l'a dit ce vote utile était
concentré sur les deux finalistes
potentiel là cette année il se concentre
sur quatre candidats pas moins de qure
candidats et pour Marine Le Pen François
Fillon ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon on a à peu
près 10 à 15 % de leurs écteurs qui
disent on va voter pour lui même si
c'est pas exactement notre candidat de
cœur mais c'est parce que c'est celui
dont on pense qu'il sera au second tour
pour le candidat du mouvement en marche
la proportion d'électeurs influencés par
le vote utile est beaucoup plus forte un
électeur sur deux d'Emmanuel Macron est
dans cette logique de vote utile un des
ressorts principaux du vote Macron c'est
justement sa capacité à être au second
tour si des enquêtes ou des observateurs
commençaient à indiquer que
manifestement Emmanuel Macron ne sera
pas au second tour là on verra il y un
effet boule de neige inversé hein et une
partie de ces électeurs qui sont là
encore une fois pour l'envoyer au second
tour pourrait reconsidérer leur jugement
aujourd'hui 30 % des électeurs ne savent
toujours pas quel bulletin ils
glisseront dans l'urne dimanche des
indécis qui pourraient décider de voter
utile ch disait en titre jamais un
scrutin de premier tour de présidentiel
n'a paru aussi serré les sondages
prédisent tous un resserement entre
quatre candidats mais les marges
d'erreur restent élevées rendant tout
pronostic particulièrement incertain
explication Samia deschir avec Nelson
gen deux petits pour c'est l'écart
maximum entre les deux candidats en tête
dans les sondages quel que soit
l'Institut on est donc dans la marge
d'erreur de plus ou moins 2,5 %. plus
concrètement un candidat crédité
aujourd'hui de 20 % François Fillon par
exemple se situe en réalité entre 17,5
et 22,5 % jean-Pierre Sueur est le
co-auteur d'une loi qui oblige les
médias à mentionner cette marge d'erreur
problème ils le font rarement quand on
publie un chire sans indiquer la marge
d'erreur on trompe les gens en
2002 tout le monde pensait que Lionel
Jospin était devant Jean-Marie Le Pen
résultat de l'élection Jean-Marie Le Pen
est devant Lionel Jospin pourquoi parce
qu'on n pas regardé qu'il y avait 1 de%
ou 2 % de différence entre les deux
candidats et ça c'est la marge d'erreur
c'est plus ou moins de 5 souvent donc ça
peut retourner les sondeurs ne nient pas
l'existence de cette marge d'erreur mais
l'erreur justement serait surtout de se
focaliser uniquement sur les chiffres
des intentions de vote ça montre bien
qu'aujourd'hui les sondages doiv être
pris pour ce qu'ils sont et pas
forcément pour ce qu'on aimerait qu'ils
soi sont pas des outils de prévision ce
sont des outils qui permettent
d'indiquer et ils sont d'autant plus
efficaces que l'on comprend les
dynamique plutôt queon mesure au
demi-point près le score de chacun des
candidats si les sondages donnent tous
des résultats différents selon les
il est vrai qu'il rendent tous compte
d'une même dynamique qure candidats en
tête dans un mouchoir de
poche et on ouvre le débat avec mes
invités qui m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau
Bruno jeanar bonsoir vous êtes directeur
général adjoint d'opinion merci d'être
avec nous l blondot également sur ce
plateau bonsoir politologue professeur
de sciences politiques à la Sorbonne
merci à tous les deux Bruno jambard on a
évoqué le nombre d'indécis cette
volatilité électoral de l'opinion
publique est-ce que dans ce contexte
inédit ça a modifié vos méthodes de
travail par exemple les méthodes de
travail évoluent en permanence elles
évoluent parce que c'est un outil
imparfait qui rencontre des défis
nouveaux à peu près à chaque élection et
et donc on est obligé de de réfléchir à
à des je dirais des des évolutions je
crois que beaucoup plus que
l'incertitude qui a toujours existé dans
les dernières élections présidentielles
à quelques jours du scrutin ce sont des
phénomènes comme l'élection de Trump ou
le brexit qui ont beaucoup aussi
interrogé la profession et nous ont
aussi permis de de de réchce que vous
avez just tiré les enseignements ou
c'est un climat de défiance aussi qui
s'est installé envers les les sondeurs
depuis C ces deux événements que vous
évoquez tirer les enseignements c'est
difficile à dire parce que il y a une
contradiction en fait vis-à-vis des
sondages c'est qu'à la fois on est très
critique et en même temps on refuse d'en
admettre l'imperfection et je dirais
l'incertitude c'està-dire le fait que on
ne va pas avec avec un sondage pouvoir
mesurer au point prè ce qui se passera
dimanche donc donc je dirais que c'est
essayer de de surtout de rappeler un
certain nombre de règles et notamment de
rappeler ses incertitude ces notions de
marge d'erreur ces notions aussi
d'imperfection de l'outil dans la
sélection des échantillons dans la
mesure électorale ouis blandot c'est
vrai qu'on parlait de ce nombre
d'électeurs indécis comment vous
l'expliquez finalement est-ce estce que
c'est de l'insatisfaction par rapport à
l'offre électorale oui il faut dire
qu'effectivement le ces élections
arrivent dans un dans un contexte de
très grande défiance à l'égard des deux
partis politiques principaux qui jusqu'à
présent se disputaient l'accès au au
second tour c'est aussi une élection qui
a produit beaucoup d'événements
inattendus les
affaires qui a favoriser l'émergence
d'un candidat dont finalement on sait
peu de chos et qu'on a du mal à
étalonner d'un certain point de vue
Emmanuel Macron donc il y a
effectivement un contexte assez
exceptionnel qui se reflète dans les
ures mais n'oublions pas euh qu'il que
au moins un quart de la population ou en
tout cas des gens qui vont voter se
décident dans les toutes dernières
heures euh donc dans dans dans les
derniers jours et qu'il faut toujours
regarder finalement les scores que font
les candidats euh sur les les ceux qui
sont décidés à voter hein donc ça n'est
qu'une partie de la population et ceux
qui déclarent ne pas euh changer
c'est-à-dire être sûr de leur vote ce
qui fait des proportions relativement
faibles hein de c'est c'est les 2/ers
aujourd'hui des personnes interrogées
qui sont dans ce contexte- làà et donc
il faut manier les sondages avec
infiniment de précaution ouais on
entendait Jean-Pierre suur évoquer cette
question de la marge d'erreur est-ce
qu'elle est suffisamment prise en compte
selon
vous ça dépend ce qu'on appelle prise en
compte nous notre objectif est pas de la
prendre en compte pour changer les
résultats des sondages mais c'est de
rappeler qu'elle existe et de rappeler
que par exemple quand on a deux ou trois
points de écart entre deux candidats
rien ne garantit que l'ordre inverse ne
sera pas n'est pas en fait l'état réel
de l'opinion euh et puis de toute façon
ce qui est difficile sur cette histoire
de marge d'erreur c'est que il y a la
marge d'erreur du sondage statistique
mais il y a aussi euh la marge d'erreur
qui est liée au au biaet
d'échantillonnage on n'a pas des
échantillons parfaits parce
qu'aujourd'hui dans un dans dans le
monde réel il n'est pas possible de
mesurer parfaitement euh l'état d'esprit
de la population donc il il faut aussi
rappeler ça maintenant euh ce qui est
important c'est de regarder les
dynamiques les évolutions euh de
regarder ces différentes situations et
puis je crois de ne pas se concentrer
uniquement sur ces questions d'intention
de vote d'essayer de comprendre ce qu'il
y a dans la tête des électeurs dans leur
motivation de vote dans leurs
préoccupation et je crois que
effectivement il y a beaucoup de
d'éléments dans dans la situation
politique actuelle du pays la défiance à
l'égard des grands partis euh les
difficultés à faire campagne qu'on a vu
à cause des événements extérieurs qui
qui doivent alerter sur je dirais
l'incertitude qui règne autour de ce
scrutin est-ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui pardon que le qui de tête
pour être modifié quand même d'ici
dimanche non je pense que les deux
finalistes sortiront des quatre premiers
en tête des sondages je pense que après
on verra bien lesquels sortiront il y a
quand même il faut toujours le rappeler
même s'il y a une marge d'erreur une
plus grande probabilité normalement que
les finalistes soient parmi les deux
premiers plutôt que parmi les deux
suivants même si ça peut aussi arriver
ouis blandio oui dans un monde politique
idéal ce que n'est pas notre monde
politique on publierait des fourchettes
c'est-à-dire que en fait au lieu de se
focaliser sur des points 5 ou des des
évolutions d'un point on dirait que tous
les candidats se situent
entre 18 et 22 % mais ce serait beaucoup
moins spectaculaire et on pourrait
beaucoup moins gloser ou interpréter ces
résultats et en particulier l'aspect
spectaculaire et un peu magique qu'on
les sondages aujourd'hui auprès des
commentateurs et en particulier auprès
de la presse auprès de vos confrères
fait qu'il est impossible de publier des
fourchettes alors que ce serait
finalement la logique des sondages que
de le faire la logique statistique des
sondages et ça nous aiderait finalement
à prendre de la distance par rapport aux
chiffres qui nous sont donnés alors
peut-être la réponse du sondeur sur
cette non mais effectivement mais la
difficulté sur la notion de marge
d'erreur c'est que quand vous avez un
candidat à 22 effectivement il peut être
entre 18 et 24 si on résume sauf que la
probabilité qu'il soit à 18 ou à 24 est
moins forte que celle qu'il soit à 22
statistiquement donc on voit bien qu'il
y a pas de réponse idéale alors ce qu'il
faut c'est toujours rappeler que
effectivement quand il y a deux ou trois
points d'écart il faut faire attention
parce que les les candidats peuvent être
dans un ordre inversé et je crois aussi
que il faut faire attention aux accents
qui sont mis sur effectivement des
évolutions qui sont marginales + 1 - 1
nous par exemple che Opin on a fait le
choix de ne jamais publier des demip
parce que on pense que ça renforce le
sentiment de précision d'un outil qui
n'est pas précis au point près et donc
c'est important aussi d'essayer de
d'envoyer des signaux de ce type ou le
blandu on a vu tout à l'heure les
candidats aussi bien brandir le spectre
du vote utile on voit bien que ça
recouvre une réalité différente selon
les candidats est-ce que ça ça rebat
aussi les cartes dans le contexte actuel
cette question du vote utile alors le
vote utile bon d'abord il faut le
définir hein un vote utile c'est quand
un électeur vote pour un candidat qui
n'est pas celui qu'il préfère hein ni
celui qu'il qu'il souhaiterait voir à
priori gouverner et ça a été mesuré
c'est-à-dire qu'aux élections de 2002
qui par bien des aspects ressemblent
l'élection présidentielle de 2002 le
fameux 21 avril ressemble par bien des
aspects à la à à la à l'élection
présente euh une étude d'un Canadien
André Blair a montré que 10 % des gens
n'avaient pas voté au premier tour pour
le candidat qu'il souhaitait voir
devenir président de la République ça
devient quelque chose d'extrêmement
important et on voit bien à quel point
finalement les résultats de sondage
constituent les paramètres à partir
desquels se dessine le vote utile il est
clair que le vote utile en l'occurrence
par exemple si on raisonne à gauche le
vote utile il joue à la fois pour Macron
vis-à-vis de des deux autres candidats
et pour Mélenchon vis-à-vis d'amont en
fait ce vote utile il est vraiment très
très présent mais il est impossible de
le quantifier scientifiquement sauf à
postériori et c'est c'est assez
compliqué ouis Breno jambar est-ce que
vous avez vous pensez que les sondages
peuvent justement influencer les
électeurs qui vont je le disais se m en
stratège et développer des stratégies de
voeur utile dès le premier tour il est
évident que les sondages influencent la
manière dont se déroule une une campagne
électorale dont se déroule le débat
médiatique autour de la campagne et donc
indirectement les électeurs maintenant
ce qui a été dit est très juste
c'està-dire que on voit bien qu'il y a
des phénomènes contradictoire dans le
vote utile il peut y avoir des électeurs
qui se disent qu'aujourd'hui le vote
utile à gauche bah c'est finalement de
voter pour Mélenchon parce qu'on a un
vrai candidat de gauche et d'autres qui
se disent que c'est de voter Macron
parce qu'on veut éviter par exemple un
duel Fillon Le Pen à droite c'est pareil
est-ce que des électeurs du Front
national vont voter pour Fillon en se
disant que Marine Le Pen a toutes les
chances d'être qualifié qu'on peut
essayer de de porter un autre candidat
droite ça ça a des phénomènes
contradictoires donc la vraie la
question c'est est-ce que ça change
fondamentalement les résultats moi je ne
crois pas parce que ça fait partie c'est
une influence parmi d'autres et un
électeur il est soumis à plein
d'influence au moment d'un scrutin et
les sondages en sont une mais ça ça
n'est pas la seule influence et donc on
ne peut pas résumer au sondage au
sondage je dirais la décision électorale
d'un électeur ouais ça influence aussi
la stratégie des candidats qui se
mettent à cibler tel ou telle personne
tel ou tel adversaire Lio très
clairement c'està-dire que ça influence
le moral des candidats on voit très bien
que sur le camp de de Benoît amont la
publication des résultats de sondage bon
est un peu lourde c'est un peu c'est un
peu difficile ça influence finalement le
traitement des candidats par les médias
et par les autres candidats donc
l'influence majeure des sondages elle
est sur le contexte politique peut-être
plus que sur l'électeur et je suis
d'accord pour dire que le la décision
électorale elle est faite d'un nombre de
paramètres qui est très très très grand
et que les résultats des sondages ne
sont qu'un des éléments de ces
paramètres ou dernière question Bruno
jambard on parlait du vote utile il y a
aussi cette question du vote caché on
sait que le camp fioniste mise beaucoup
sur cet aspect est-ce que vous arrivez à
le sonder justement ce vote caché par
définition s'il y a un vote caché on ne
le sait pas et on ne le voit pas dans
les enquêtes préélectoral moi je crois
pas à la théorie du vote caché parce que
je pense qu'il y a pas de raison de
penser que des électeurs nous disent ou
ne nous disent pas qu'il voterai pour
François fon en revanche il y a un
phénomène qui existe on voit bien qu'il
y a un contexte puon l'end oui pour
Marine Le Pen mais il y a un contexte
émotionnel particulier sur l'électorat
de droite cette année qui est euh une
une je dirais une tension entre la
posture morale qui est de d'être choqué
par ce qu'a fait François fillan ou ce
qu'on lui reproche et aussi le sentiment
qu'il est le seul candidat à défendre un
certain nombre de propositions qui sont
les leurs et donc la question c'est de
savoir comment les électeurs vont
dénouer cette tension émotionnelle
probablement que pour une partie d'entre
eux ils le feront que dimanche dans
l'isoloir et ça évidemment ça met un peu
en danger je dirais la mesure qu'on l'
qu'on fait à travers les sondages très
très rapidement le le problème n'est pas
forcément dans le vote caché puisque
avec le fait que les les les sociétés de
sondage utilise Internet les gens
hésitent moins à donner le le leur voix
ce qui est plus problématique me
semble-t-il ce sont les catégories de
population qui sont susceptibles de
voter pour Marine Le Pen ou pour
François Fillon et leur probabilité de
participer qui est différente le chiffre
important des derniers sondages c'est de
savoir que plus de 80 % des électeurs de
Marine Le Pen sont sûr de de le leur
vote et c'est un peu la même chose pour
François Fillon alors que les les
probabilités d'aller voter sont moins
fortes chez les autres candidats ça
c'est vraiment une donnée merci merci
blondot merci beaucoup Bruno jambar pour
votre éclairage al la on évoqué la fin
de campagne difficile pour Emmanuel
Macron il en est de même pour Marine Le
Pen la candidate dont le meeting
parisien a été perturbé hier par
l'intrusion de de femenes et des
incidents à l'extérieur avait choisi
pagas en ha de Vienne pour s'adresser au
monde agricole reportage de Cécile Siou
etise
grigoire à pajas sur les terres
limousines les militants FN sa
faire Julie 20 an va voter pour la
première fois à une présidentielle pour
elle il n'y a pas eu de doute j'ai pas
honte de voter FN parce que il y a rien
de mal et que ben voilà c'est c'est pour
notre France quoi c'est c'est tout
personnellement je n'accepte pas ce
qu'il disent on va dire de l'autre bord
j'accepte pas il y a certaines choses
qui se font pas et voilà décor champêtre
et scénographie bien soigné ici laavenue
de Marine Le Pen est un événement on ne
l'a pas vu depuis 2010 là aujourd'hui
pour nous c'est un grand honneur et une
grande joie de l'accueillir on en est
ravi parce qu'elle va pouvoir vraiment
être en prise directe avec les le monde
agricole rural qui souffre beaucoup ici
en Limousin ça va bONJ Christophe le
chevalier Christophe le chevalier qui a
mis à disposition son exploitation
espère faire venir un maximum
d'agriculteurs déçus comme lui 1/ers des
agriculteurs vontre Front national tout
ça c'est parce que on en a marre d'en
avoir marre et quand les gens on marre
d'en avoir marre et bien ils veulent que
ça change alors soit d'autres
gouvernements font les choses et
changent les choses et ça va mieux ils
l'ont pas fait donc maintenant il y a
une personne qui aujourd'hui tient s pas
elle tient ses promesses elle va elle
dit et elle va faire sur ces terres
traditionnellement à gauche la président
du FN attire aussi quelques curieux les
fameux indécis vous savez pour qui vous
allez voter
alors là pas du tout pas du tout pouro
vous êtes là aujourd'hui et ben je suis
venu pour voir c'est tout pour voir
c'est pour voir Marine Le Pen pour pour
voir son programme et puis c'est c'est
Toutin voilà non non je sais pas du tout
pour qui je vais
voter acclamé comme une star Marine Le
Pen cajole son auditoire et brosse les
territoires ruraux dans le sens du poil
et puis c'est l'épicerie qui ferme le
rideau ensuite c'est le restaurant du
centrebourg et puis la vie part tout
simplement et puis comme la vi part vos
enfants partent il part pour aller
chercher dans la grande ville d'à côté
les moyens de trouver un emploi en
baisse dans les sondages elle a aussi
ressorti ses classiques contre
l'immigration qui font écho dans la
foule et notre chroniqueuse St Tran nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau avec vous Tam
on va passer au crible les propos des
candidats à l'élection présidentielle on
va parler ensemble de la nouvelle mesur
proposé par Marine Le Pen sur
l'immigration mais avant cela bien on
l'écoute c'était lors de son meeting
hier à
Paris France je déciderai d'un moratoire
immédiat sur toute l'immigration légale
pour arrêter ce délire cette situation
incontrôlée qui nous entraîne vers le
fond un moratoire pour faire le point de
la situation avant de mettre en place de
nouvelles règles et une nouvelle
régulation beaucoup plus drastique plus
raisonnable plus humaine plus gérable
alors on vient d'entendre Marine Le Pen
faut un moratoire sur l'immigration
légale pour faire le point dit-elle sur
la situation en quoi ça va consister
alors on a effectivement eu quelques
précisions ce matin grâce à l'interview
qu'elle a donné sur RTL le moratoire
qu'elle propose il consiste à stopper
l'immigration pendant quelques semaines
il serait temporaire à afin de voir
quelle politique mettre en place pour
arriver à l'objectif du Front national
réduire l'immigration légale à un sol de
10000 personnes par an ensuite et bien
tout le monde n'est pas concerné hein
par ce moratoire déjà les visas
touristiques ne seront pas visés Marine
Le Pen pense seulement au visas de
longue durée et parmi ces visas de
longue durée elle ne pense pas aux
étudiants mais avant tout à
l'immigration familiale notamment le
regroupement familial qu'elle considère
comme considérable alors quelles
seraient les personnes concernées
combien seraient-elles et bien déjà pour
savoir le cadre général sachez que selon
le ministère de l'Intérieur en 2016 il y
a eu 227000 titres de séjour qui ont été
délivré et je précise d'emblé que le
solde migratoire est bien moindre selon
l'INC la même année il a été seulement
de 67000 personnes ensuite et bien
l'immigration familiale qui est visée
par Marine Le Pen elle représente entre
1/3 et la moitié de tous ces titres long
sé jours c'est-à-dire 88000 personnes
l'an dernier et c'est stable depuis les
10 dernières années c'est toujours entre
80000 et 90000 personnes la majorité
ensuite de l'immigration familiale il
faut savoir que pour l'essentiel c'est
de la famille qui vient rejoindre un
français et qu'enfin le regroupement
familial stricto s'insu c'est-à-dire
quand un étranger en situation régulière
en France depuis plus de 18 mois fait
venir sa famille et bien tout cela ce
n'est pas du tout considérable he
contrairement à ce que dit Marine Le Pen
c'est même plutôt très modeste seulement
11500 personnes en 2015 on n' pas encore
les chiffres de 2016 mais c'est tout à
fait comparable donc le mouratoire
proposé par Marine Le Pen concernerait
environ 90000 personnes au maximum
est-ce qu'il est conforme au droit et
bien là il y a vraiment débat de
juristes débat d'interprétation ce matin
j'ai parlé avec l'avocat Vincent berger
spécialiste de droit européen lui il
pense que c'est compatible avec la
jurprudence de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et le fameux article 8
sur le droit à la vie privée et
familiale parce que en même temps selon
lui la Cour européenne des droits de
l'homme respecte la souveraineté des
États qui en clair sont libres
d'admettre et expulser comme ils
l'entendent tout autre son de cloche
j'ai également parlé avec le spécialiste
de droit public Serge Slama pour lui un
tel moratoire passe par la voie
réglementaire alors il y aurait des
recours d'association devant le Conseil
d'État qui invaliderait cette décision
un peu comme ça s'est passé pour le
décret antimimigration de Donald Trump
aux États-Unis alors ce moratoire c'est
une nouvelle proposition de Marine Le
Pen elle n avait pas parler he
d'ailleurs lors de sa campagne jusqu'à
prés et d'ailleurs si on regarde bien
son programme et bien cette mesure ne
figure pas dans 640 qure propositions
mais il faut savoir aussi que c'est un
retour aux fondamentaux du Front
national pour elle pour remobiliser la
base 5 jours avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle une stratégie
classique chez Marine Le Pen qui liit en
fait immigration et terrorisme
aujourd'hui comme hier d'ailleurs elle a
fait référence à Mohamed Mera on va
l'écouter avec moi il n'y aurait pas eu
Mohamed Mera français grâce au droit du
sol
binationale délinquant réchidivis le
tueur de militaires et d'enfants
juifs combien de Mohamed Mera dans les
avions les bateaux qui chaque jour
arrivve en France rempli
d'immigrés vous avez donc entendu he
cette année elle a déclaré que Mohamed
Mera est français grâce au droit du sol
et on l'a entendu lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle en 2012 elle
utilisait alors Mohamed Mera pour que
l'immigration fasse peur c'était un mois
avant l'élection en résumé et bien le
moratoire proposé par Marine Le Pen
concernerait moins de la moitié de
l'immigration légale en France cette
mesure elle fait débat au niveau du
droit pour être invalidé par le juge
administratif reste que l'essentiel pour
la candidate et bien c'est le signal
c'est de radicaliser son discours juste
avant l'élection une constante au Front
national merci beaucoup th pour toutes
vos précisions c'est la fin à présent de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi tout de suite les preuves de
vérité spécial élection présidentielle
invité ce so ir Nicolas dupontignant Yan
brossin soutien de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
le sénateur maire de Lyon j colon qui
soutient lui Emmanuel Macron bonne
soirée et à demain
[Musique]
18h